[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we
sift through philosophy find practical
advice you can use in your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and
my co-host is dr greg sadler today we
are going to be talking about
the meanings of truth and this is a bit
of a
hold over from our our last show where
we were going to talk about
memory and truth and we did talk a lot
about memory
and we did mention truth a few times but
we didn't get into
some of the the meat that we wanted to
delve into last time so we decided we
needed to do a whole show about that
and who knows we might keep on going
after that if we don't get through
everything that we've we've settled on
uh and the memory show was a lot of fun
um that was a great conversation
i think when we get into these
epistemological
issues they often seem very abstract as
you're approaching them but then when
you think about
how many ways they figure in our life
and our
shared experiences and the things we
argue about and
the things we worry about they're
they're actually really important
for um you know like you said you know
we
try to find practical advice that you
can use in your everyday life
not everything that we're going to say
is necessarily going to be words of
advice but it's things that you could
you could apply things that you could
get some mileage out of
right right the whole
process of trying to understand us and
to try to create a better
map of reality for ourselves based on
you know both philosophy and what we've
been able to go through you know
scientific inquiry
uh and and then credit you know
create a metaphysics that allows us to
actually work through the
world that we happen to inhabit yeah and
the consequences for
believing things that aren't true it
really varies i mean some things
you know we were talking just before the
show about some sci-fi stuff and and
really what we do when we're reading
sci-fi is we're allowing ourselves to be
in a certain way lied to about what
exists
and what's going on but but it's
entertainment it's called buy-in in the
industry
oh okay yeah yeah and and you know that
that is often not
pernicious but you know we live in a
time where
people are thinking that it's a terrible
idea to get you know vaccinated against
a
pandemic disease right and that's got
some significant
uh impact for for a lot of people or
there's all sorts of beliefs about like
who's trying to screw over
who and take things away from them and
then people get targeted
people make all sorts of bad decisions
about their finances or relationships or
you know
really anything that can involve
planning if you're deprived of the truth
you're kind of in a bad way right and if
you're the one who's depriving yourself
of the truth because you know it's
uncomfortable or
you've bought into things that you
shouldn't have
uh or would you know bad for you to have
done
that's that's really quite a tragedy
isn't it right the
the difference between i guess being
deceived externally
versus being deceived internally like
once you've
bought into a lie even though there's
you know a preponderance of evidence
actually shows that yeah not holding a
uh i guess an idea that corresponds to
reality yeah as a
primer for something to talk about
sooner
part of what we're going to talk about
here is
theories of truth and by these we mean
sort of
grand perspectives on what it means for
something to be true
and i think people are often mixed up
not just about like
individual things like is the door open
or not you know or
if i eat this uh rotten cheese while i
get sick or not you know
is it okay if i if i just cut the bad
parts off and then
then eat around or something like that
those are particular
matters right but then there's like
broader things
where you see people and the way that
they're going about things
you can say wow that person is mixed up
when it comes to how we
engage in inquiry how we sort out
claims about you know what's real what's
not real
um they're mixed up sometimes about how
how we would look at authorities you
know um
and so i think studying these theories
of truth can actually be
helpful for for quite a few people in
thinking about well what does it mean
for things to actually be
true how do we arrive at truth
and this is the core of epistemology and
we have a number of different
uh avenues to walk down here um as we'll
get into but i know that you had some
uh i think i thought common sayings
uh that uh from history that you want to
talk about i thought i thought it'd be
good for us to like kick these around a
little bit i i think everybody's
heard most of these um
you know for example pontius pilate in
the
narrative when you know christ is
brought before him he says this this
phrase what is truth right and some
people kind of portray him as if he's
like sneering like what is truth you
know
it doesn't matter at all but other
people read it and they're like
hey maybe this guy is actually asking
well what's what's truth you know maybe
you know
uh tell me tell me what's going on and
then jesus doesn't say anything and you
know the whole thing
goes on but that's a really central
question um and
and you've got a a leader you know
somebody who's i think governor right
uh punches pilot of of that region and
and so you know somebody when somebody
like that says what is truth
and they're not just being cynical
it's probably something to be concerned
about
right well i guess
if if someone has no way of discerning
truth
then that might be something to be
worried about especially in
that position yeah um but i i'm very
happy when i hear
uh leaders say uh i don't know
but at least i'll look to find out
because if you're just saying like
things to sound like you actually know
yeah
uh this is kind of like perception is
better than reality i guess
you know many politicians don't ever
want to seem to be like
they might not know something because
they'll that would be used as a cudgel
against them
but i think the the process of inquiry
is better than the process of knowing
yeah you know you bring up leaders and
so we've got political leaders and that
that's a big issue
with them but we could also talk about
like in in business you know the the
people who are the spokes people
presumably they should know what they're
talking about or if a ceo is questioned
about their product
we want them i mean they might lie but
they
they might also just not say anything
who knows
and then you know we could talk about
academic institutions
that's one where very often the people
who are running academic institutions at
least here in our
our country and i'm thinking about like
colleges and universities
they're not academics they're more like
business leaders
you know they're the people who can
raise money and
and budget and make decisions like that
and quite often
what they're they're putting out there
is truth
um almost immediately gets you know
examined and then taken down by by
people who
are uh closer to the ground
so to speak and and we can talk about
all sorts of other
venues maybe there's something about
truth and leadership that we
we should explore as a separate topic uh
down the line
what does leadership really require
of goods right you know
any of these other ones that you really
wanted to dig into
well so what do you make of this one
this is aristotle talking about
his teacher plato says though we love
both the truth and our friends
piety requires us to honor the truth
first so this is
you know something aristotle says where
he diverges from
from plato and you know the idea is well
listen my my teacher who i studied with
all this time and i love the guy he says
this
but the truth isn't there we we should
you know go the other way um
i mean and we could apply this to not
just like a teacher-student relationship
what about in your family you know
what what if you find out that the
origin
story that your family has been telling
all this time you know you do some
genetic testing and you know you'd start
looking at newspaper clippings isn't
really that
true should you upset the proverbial
apple cart
and you know tell everybody no no no
here's here's what actually happened
um you know great example of this is
the families that claim to have native
american heritage
and it's almost always a cherokee you
know in in the background
what if you do genetic testing and you
find out there isn't any of that going
on
um should you like confront them about
that and say listen you're
you're doing this thing that's kind of
popular
and playing off of other people's
ethnicities using this trope um
you know i i don't know maybe maybe it
is very important that
regardless of what our affective
you know friend-like familial connection
is with people that we have to honor the
truth more
i i know i've been that kind of person
and that sometimes creates friction
i kind of suspect that you're that kind
of person too
right so there there's like
yes i definitely i'm just thinking about
like
my own life and my own like family and
like
you know i'm thinking about first the
things that uh we don't talk about or we
do talk about
in in play company type things and so
they there's definitely political
divides and there are certain things
that i won't quite bring up because i
don't believe that they
um really uh
have a grasp on reality on certain
things
um based on their kind of like their
political tribe but i don't
always bring it up like i brought it up
like once or twice but i let it drop
for the while because it's it doesn't
actually benefit
me or the family or the uh
coherence they're in of of or the
cohesiveness of the family
um in that regard and so i'm like i'm
thinking about like what what is the
good
that are arrives from this or derives
from this and
as long as it's not leading them to make
uh particularly like harmful decisions
for other people then
i usually let it lie but if i do believe
it's going to cause harmful things then
yeah i definitely
am out there being a paladin for truth i
mean there is something to be said
for when to say things or what way to
say things
and how how much to push you know if
you're
um constantly
the truth teller um that i'm all that
almost might have like a similar thing
to like the boy who cried wolf
right the boy cried wolf lies all the
time and if you're telling
uncomfortable truths to people all the
time maybe after a certain point they
just tune you out
you know it's equally ineffective
so i suppose we could talk about the how
we make truth effective
um right do you think uh al gore is that
you know he has he been on the radar
lately um
all i know is the al gore of like you
know the 2000 election and then
um i was thinking the inconvenient truth
specifically
that was kind of his wardrobe for the
longest time and yeah anytime i see him
he still
talks about it okay um but like he
doesn't get as much purchase anymore
i don't know exactly there's probably a
number of reasons but like
if that's if you're always just rallying
against like hey
we're we're you know slowly sliding
towards an apocalypse
you know people don't tend to want to
hear that
yeah there's there's a certain um
in our time at least there's a certain
anesthetization that takes place when
you keep hearing bad news over and over
again i mean again think about covet
right
so when when the covid um pandemic first
began and we had the lockdown here in
milwaukee and we're all like oh we got
to be really careful let's wipe
everything down
and you know now everyone's going to
wash their hands i mean
some people still weren't washing their
hands obviously
you know but we'll wear masks and be
really careful about who we spend time
with although
of course there were some people who
were partying and doing
things like that after a while you get
to the point where
you just get kind of worn down with
hearing more and more stuff about it
think about how
the the the death toll i mean
it's you know for a while got to 3 000
uh people a day yeah like one and a half
september learn that's a september 11th
a day yeah
and and i think people became kind of
numb to that after a while
um and those are truths you know um i
mean there's a lot of debate
you know well you know were these really
coveted deaths or were they coveted
related
or were they things that were getting
counted as covet even that they though
they weren't and we can say well there's
there's some
uh questions at least i don't myself
have that much suspicion
when it comes to those sorts of things
but i know there's a lot of suspicion
out there that that you know these were
not accurate
but then we have to ask yourself well
how the hell would they know
the people who are saying that they're
inaccurate what do they have
that shows us you know a better picture
of things
uh a more accurate picture of things um
let's talk about maybe a few others of
these
um so henry david thoreau says rather
than love then money than fame give me
truth and you could say okay that that
makes sense you really like the truth
um is it really that valuable though
to have have the truth i mean if you do
have love
if you do have money if you do have fame
couldn't you get by
with maybe less truth
what do you think maybe being lied to
every so often but you know
people give you affection and money and
uh i guess
um love money and fame
at least from a stoke perspective are
externals
whereas truth is something that can
actually lead you towards
making a virtuous action which is
actually a good
so i guess i would tend to agree with
throw here
from a stoic perspective one of the
virtues is directly concerned with truth
and that's wisdom
you know so you you couldn't possibly be
wise being disconnected from
truth and and saying ah yeah this other
stuff that's better for me i'll take
that
instead uh i i would like to go
back to the aristotle one just for uh
yeah concerning
so like it depends on the group that i'm
in
and there are certain groups where there
are certain relationships that need to
be
maintained with like you know uh a light
touch
all right that's a good way to put it
yeah and to know when to choose your
battles
um but then i also i have a group that
um
i i talk with at least weekly if not
more
um who like one of our like primary
basis for
our discussion is no dogmas like you
you can discuss and argue for anything
and
just because you argue for something or
or not
argue or something that is not a pr
there's no prerequisite for you
being here or not and so that that's i
really love being in that place because
i can just like
um you know go right into the the debate
and there's there's no pretext to be
like maybe hurting someone's feelings
it's all just like
it's just we're just talking about ideas
and if we can divorce those
do you feel a greater sense of freedom
right right
is part of it and you're you're more
able to
be be yourself or to try out ideas or
what else would be goods that are
associated with that to
you'd have like genuine good good faith
conflict
right and those are things you can't
have in the other setting
right right because both others most
almost every other setting like if you
present a view that might be
a little bit outside the norm you could
just get absolutely ostracized
yeah i i have a friend who's
quite wealthy and um he's very
honest too about how he came by his
wealth he's like yeah i just happen to
have made a couple decisions that i
you know i i didn't have like inside
knowledge or anything they just happened
to be right place right time and
things worked out and he says that there
is a
um a real difficulty in getting people
to be
honest and straight with you once you're
rich yeah
you know and you know i have to take it
i'm not rich so i have to kind of
take take him at his word on that but it
makes sense
you know um and he brought up um you
know employees
and and other people he brought up
relatives
and then he brought up um in case of
dating you can never
quite be sure that somebody really likes
you for you
you know rather than for all the things
the money
not just your money but all the things
the money can can uh
offer um that's why you see a lot of
especially professionals athletes will
keep their
friends from before they were rich and
famous
um as a because they can rely on them as
actual friends right
that's an interesting idea so i wanted
to bring up
um this other one and this is more of a
pop culture one you know i i think
everybody's familiar with it
you want the truth you can't handle the
truth right that came from
a movie that had jack nicholson and tom
cruise
and jack nicholson was the one who said
it on the stand as colonel jessup
after they you know they'd killed a guy
and he's saying
the truth is something essentially that
only certain people can
can have only certain people are
entitled to it
because they they can understand the
context
now i i want to say that okay there's
something to that
right not everybody necessarily is
entitled to
every truth and some people
can't handle some truths that you you
might tell them but i also want to push
back against that and say
well maybe even if people can't handle
it
maybe they are entitled to the truth if
they ask for it
what do you think i i'm not i'm not
completely settled on this myself
immediate thought
says that yeah like there should not be
any truths that are
well shoot okay so i'm thinking about
things so like i'm thinking about
uh edge case nuclear proliferation okay
you know um if everyone had the exact
way to produce a nuclear bomb we'd be in
real trouble
yeah especially if it was easy to do uh
yeah
uh and so there are certain truths that
need to be guarded in that regard but i
guess
if we're only talking about truths of
like what you
you can like deal with and try to make
some understanding about especially like
this
him choosing everything you can't handle
the truth and
uh because why they they kill this
person i kind of extrapolate this to
you know being a general and deciding to
send
troops in knowing that you're like you
know half of them might die because
that's what your casualties average
is but you're like trying to go for a
larger thing and
a lot of people wouldn't be able to make
that decision and want to be able to
accept the truth that this is you know i
guess how you
deal with that sort of situation
but i don't think hiding that type of
truth
is particularly beneficial especially if
you give them the tools
to actually help them understand
how to understand it in in the proper
context
the problem is that a lot of times these
unfortunate truths are presented
in a way to use as a cudgel against
other people especially for power
um in because they intentionally
uh remove or obfuscate the
context in which these decisions were
made
that's a really interesting point about
the difference between
speaking a truth basically to like knock
somebody else down
or to refute them or to you know be the
person who gets to
take over and speaking the truth because
it's the truth and
people you know ought to have you know
correct
opinions about things and and are
entitled to that i think those are two
very
different things and you know one of the
things that i've been thinking about for
quite a while is it's possible to tell a
essentially false story that is true
it's true in its parts but then it's the
way you put them together and the way
you structure it
that you you uh tell a false narrative
and then
when when the person is called on it
they can fall back on the bits and
pieces and they're like oh but this is
true over here
and it's very rare that they get they
get called on the
totality of falsehood that they're
engaging in and so you can have things
that are locally true
being put together into a narrative or
an account that's
actually false you know
right what's it uh what's the quote um
there are something about statistics and
lies
oh oh yeah there's there's lies damned
lies and statistics right
i forgot who said that but uh yeah
uh i actually heard another thing back
when i used to be a mathematics major
and it was it was told to me by
somebody who was outside of the field
but they they'd heard this thing
never trust us a statistic you haven't
forged yourself
yeah that's why it's so important if
you're actually going to like grab
something from science
to actually potentially look at the
paper see how they actually came about
these
this data and uh yeah the study
yeah look at the the parameters of the
experiments
because you know you can massage those
in so many different ways to
get a wanted outcome
if you are well that's become a bigger
problem in recent years than it was in
the past
you know as as the sophistication of
statistical
modeling aided by you know computers
has increased there's more opportunities
to like you said to massage
and and you know kind of select the data
stuff that that's going to fit your
narrative and there's also pressure to
do so because if you can't show
statistically uh what are they called
statistically significant results
then nobody wants to publish your your
research and that means that you don't
get your paper for the year you don't
get you know grants
so there's there's a lot of uh motives
for for doing that plus fame could be
part of that right
you want to have something to say that's
interesting about what you did with
these mice over here
this drug so so you know it's easy to
find a way to
[Music]
tell a story with that data that isn't
entirely true
yeah and and to add on to that the
rewards go for people making
new discoveries and not for any of the
scientists who are doing replication
and now i guess that was the whole what
replication crisis
that kind of came to a head i don't know
eight ten years ago i want to say at
this point in time
yeah and the salt in the social sciences
yeah and it's it's still a crisis
because a lot of those studies haven't
successfully been replicated so
it hasn't gone away i guess it's it's
gotten better
it's it's as from what i've heard
um but yeah it's definitely not a solved
issue
[Laughter]
yeah so i know that you wanted to talk a
bit about the is ought divide and what
we could
draw from from that in terms of truth
right so like this this famously comes
from david hume
um i believe that the quota is like one
cannot derive
an ought from an is and an ought is like
a
a moral you should be doing this thing i
ought to
um you know uh drive safely i was like
and so the the usual usage of this is
like well how how can you
go from like a purely empirical
place and and try to make some moral
judgments about things
but it's it's not this device like we're
we're always in concert with the natural
world it is us that we have the values
and both uh implicitly stated and also
um or sorry explicitly stated and
implicit in uh our uh
upbringing that have these values
baked into them and yeah based on that
intermingling do we actually come to
certain
moral truths and moral arts and we can
based on the kind of like the fact that
we are rational agents or we all are
you know human um more or less
that uh because of by dent of our
humanity that we
have certain things that we all kind of
move towards and we can create general
odds from that
you know it's it's interesting one of
the things
that comes up whenever i teach an ethics
class
they're all there's almost always a
student at some point in the semester
who when we're looking at some sort of
moral theory perspective right and a
moral theory perspective would be
asserting some things to be moral truths
you know you should do things this way
and here's how you should evaluate stuff
and they'll say yeah but everybody
doesn't believe that you know
and then you can say yeah well sure
that's that's one of the differences
between
moral truths and what we could call
truths about the physical world or
or logical truths or things like that
that there is going to be some
disagreement it might take some moral
development or
developing a certain way of looking at
things in order to to get it some of the
time
but it's interesting because
um when i've taught logic classes
there are there are some students who
just don't get that either and
you know you look at that and you're
like well logic is supposed to be the
laws of thought you know it's like
supposed to be
this baseline that everybody is supposed
to
almost like intuitively grasp and then
you build out from that into
all sorts of cool theorems and proofs
and stuff like that
and there are some people who just
cannot grasp
the truth table for implication and you
can explain it to them
and you can like try all sorts of
different tasks and they'll just
as some of them at a certain point will
be like oh yeah now i see
and then some of them just won't get it
and um you know if if
logic is really what it's supposed to be
that should not be possible
right and it's the same thing too with
physical the truth's about like the
physical
world though you know we can our
perceptions can be off
you know um and and you know there's
that old saying well who are you going
to trust
me or your lion eyes
there's all sorts of ways in which
people get
get things wrong about um what we what
we take to be
almost like bedrock the physical world
you know
and i suppose too there's probably some
obstinacy and ordinariness
involved there's some people who are
just so contrary and that they won't
accept that like your shirt is blue and
my shirt is yellow
you know you and you tell them that they
have to they have to say the opposite
and so just your perception is it's
yellow and blue
it's not at the actual reality of the
situation
the quality that you have in your mind
is different than mine
yeah actually that reminds me this is
totally tangential but do you remember
that dress
oh yes yes yeah the blue
and gold versus the whatever yes
what was so striking about that is how
angry people got
that other people were perceiving it
differently
same thing with those sound things where
like you'd play a sound file and it
could sound like it was saying
one phrase or a different phrase and i
forget what exactly what they they were
kind of nonsensical things people would
get really upset
you know yeah but then again people get
really upset when it comes to matters of
uh taste you know um
this pie is good no there's pie socks
you know and people get really
you know if it was just purely
subjective and we we actually did follow
the you know
uh there is no dispute in matters of
taste people wouldn't get worked up
about these things but they they really
do
once again i will enjoy this tangent um
okay because i i once had a
a roommate who would not
uh follow me down to the conclusion that
there's
something as subjective versus objective
and that
i remember you to tell this story it was
really great um
so yeah it was uh she was always angry
after work um because like someone
didn't see
something the way she saw it on and
and because everything she saw was
objective truth
um it really flustered her and and
somehow i caught wind of this during one
of our conversations
i'm like what do you mean you don't know
what subjective
is and i'm like okay we can talk about
like
uh an intersection and there's a a car
accident in the intersection and you're
on
one street and there's a big building
blocking like 60 of your view of this
intersection
and someone uh on another street and
they they only had thirty percent of
their view
uh blocked from it they see one thing
you see another thing your your
individual subjective realities lead you
to
perceiving uh the i guess the primary
fault
of two different people um yeah but
uh that one of these is definitely true
or both of these can't be true at the
same time they
could both be wrong as well um because
there's a gap in both of your
perceptions
but uh she just would not walk down that
road with me that
any that there could be anything that
was not objective
um well it sounds too like
she was also committed to the view that
her view is always the best view right
well her view was objective and thus
okay anyone else that deviated from that
was not objective and thus wrong wow
that must have been a hard life yeah i i
wish her well
just not in my house i was
actually thinking as you were talking
about this about like when we're
watching
football right and there's a play
and you know we're seeing everything
from camera angles
and we don't actually see what the refs
who are
like calling penalties are seeing
because there's no camera
i mean i i hate to bring this up because
maybe somebody will actually start
suggesting putting cameras on on the
refs like we do
now on on cops or on other people right
and then that'll be broadcast um
you know we don't see exactly what the
ref sees we see with the camera person
who's operating like a drone or
something like that has chosen to
to pick and there'll be like these
questionable calls right and then
they'll um you know do a replay of it
and look at it from different angles the
the two guys in the booth will talk
about it
and if it's sufficiently complex they'll
bring in joe pereira
you know i would ask him what he thinks
then five minutes have gone by of
analyzing all this stuff and um
you know do we ever get the you know the
pure
unvarnished truth of the situation
not exactly you know is it was was this
guy's foot in
you know when he caught the pass or not
or was this a bad hit you know all the
different
was this past interference all those
sort of things that that people get
really
uh upset about um you know we can kind
of know what's going on but we can't we
can't know
like from some god's eye view that takes
it everything perfectly
yeah going back to our actual
conversation i'll pose the question
uh are there differences between moral
and physical truths
and is that even a useful distinction
i mean there are in that they're they're
referring to different kinds
of matters right and
i think i think the distinction is one
that breaks down
at some points and they often do involve
each
other you know you think about any
coordinated activity that has like
internal
norms to it that people have to like get
into like you know when you're working
in a factory and people like get over
there do that you know oh you did it
wrong man you know
i mean the first day first week
sometimes when working in a factory is
usually not very pleasant because
uh you find out that there's this entire
universe that you don't know about
that everybody else on the line does and
they're all mad at you for getting it
wrong
and they they act as if um you know
they almost this is kind of like an
interesting kind of blur here because
they talk in terms of
ises in a very out sense
and you're always you know you should
have known this
and you've got got things wrong and then
you know you've kind of fit in
so i do think going back to what your
question yeah i do think there's there's
differences between those and and
logical truths and other kinds of truths
that we can talk about
but i think they blur into each other
and they often
it's hard to find them in pure isolation
you might say you know and from each
other it reminds me of uh
physicists will usually uh simplify
things uh it's just so you can get a
uh like the the basics of the idea and
they'll
they'll talk about the um there's a
spherical cow
a spherical color yeah well you wanna
reduce it to a very simple geometric
object so
it is a cow but it is also a sphere and
so it it's
it's nonsense um but it's something that
is this um how can you um
talk about the physical world um at such
a
like plain geometric physics based
area and not have like the rest of the
accoutrements that come with a cow
yeah yeah i mean if you think about it a
cow
you got the outside thing right and so
maybe that could be kind of spherical
although in minecraft it's made of
blocks and stuff like that too
but if you think about an animal in
terms of
its elementary uh
canal right starting from the mouth
going all the way to the to the rear
you know where where it's getting rid of
stuff um
that's actually kind of long and complex
you know
i mean what do we have like 36 feet of
intestines
i'm only six feet tall so all right six
six feet three inches so
you know there's a lot of stuff coiled
up around
so don't get too bad on me greg
well we should we should we should get
to talking about these uh truths
theories of truth that we're gonna get
into
and we're gonna we're gonna just jump
into talking about some of these
um and we'll see how much time we we
have for them
um you know when we when we teach this
like in a philosophy class or if you
look at textbooks or you go to wikipedia
as well
you'll see them referencing things like
the correspondence theory of truth or
coherence theory of truth or pragmatist
theory of truth
and then then some other topics as well
and you say well
why why have a whole theory of what
truth is
um shouldn't it be much more simple
shouldn't there just be like one
theory of of what truth is and you know
different
um theorists not just philosophers but
also
historians and theologians and novelists
have you know kind of kicked these
around and some people favor
one more than the other and i think that
when you look at it
you see that all of them are you know
they're getting some things right
and they're missing some other things so
you know the correspondence theory this
is one that people
very often go back to when they say
things like you know something's true if
it accords with the facts you know
uh if it represents things the way they
are and that works great
for some some things like you know like
right now
we're communicating on on zoom and we're
using these uh
backgrounds these virtual backgrounds so
we both have books
in the background and we can say that's
false you know it's just a
fake backdrop essentially that's been
created
virtually those books that are in
your background uh maybe they're real
in some place maybe it's a photograph of
something real
um but this is a real photograph
well it's a real photograph right that's
that that's correct
that's true um but it's not one that
depicts the reality of what's behind you
i know that in your place there's like
if i remember it like a door or
something like that
you've seen my studio that i'm talking
from right now so you know that there's
like
a chalkboard and some lights and
things like that not just books so we
can say that you know
the correspondence theory of truth is
good for this kind of thing we can say
are things really the way that they're
being
presented to us um or are they
are they not that way is
you know is my cat downstairs or is she
out on the street walking milwaukee you
know looking for mice or something like
that
um hopefully she's uh downstairs because
you know she's 18 years old so i don't
want her out
hunting for for mice and it could be
wrong or it could be right
right right so you know if i say to you
something like uh
you're gonna die tomorrow um because
the uh the bus is going to hit you uh
hopefully that's not true
um you know it's true if that sort of
state of affairs uh corroborates that
you could say
so i mean this is kind of a naive and
commonsensical way of looking at what it
means for things to be true and
i think we get a lot of mileage out of
this i don't think we can ever get away
from this entirely
you know using other theories of truth
we have to have
some things that are a matter of
correspondence
um but there's some problems with it
as well you know so
for example yes a potential issue is
this idea of
like it maps to reality but whenever we
create a
map in our head of reality um
the map isn't the reality it is a map of
the reality and so there's always going
to be
um some missing detail
and so the map is not the terrain is how
this is usually put forward
and i think we actually spoken about
this at least once before on the show
um yeah you know the reality too might
have changed in the process
right you i mean here's one where it's
not
map is not exactly what we would use we
might use the image of
like a picture you know we see somebody
that we haven't
talked to for a long time that maybe we
went to college with or high school
with or worked with at one time um and
we run into them and we're like wow
you've really changed you know
well the map that we had in our head no
longer corresponds to the
to the reality of the person um
and we can think of all sorts of things
like that i mean a lot of times people
don't realize that they've changed
themselves this is how um you know
people who try to exercise too hard
into their 40s and 50s and then they you
know they're really sore the next day or
they sprain themselves or they
they do some damage to their body they
still have a map of who they were
and their capacities that doesn't fit
the reality when they go to play you
know some pickup football game on the
weekend
this uh whole map in reality
if you want to put it in the other way
there's an interesting story about
on paper towns and so paper towns were
a device used to basically watermark
by companies that made maps and they
would add
fake towns to their maps so if anyone
else
reproduced their maps one for one and
they put that town on they knew
that that was fake except for
some people uh sorry some towns
actually rose up in the spot
on the maps and because
a map had a name there they named
themself
that town and so the map begat
the town you when there was no town
there
yeah that's excellent um i mean that
almost sounds like a story out of uh
jorge louis borges you know um he has
he has stories in which things like that
occur uh i mean that could be a kafka
story too though as well
um yeah i mean there's other issues too
when it comes to the correspondence
theory
um not everything is susceptible to
being mapped out
you know like when we when we say that
um
[Music]
it's it's a good thing to spread freedom
across the world what does that actually
correspond to
you know does that mean voting rights
does that mean
uh the capacity to engage in what we
call economic freedom you know to buy
and sell things i mean it gets it
a lot of things that we do this with the
words
or terms are ambiguous or um
polysemic they can mean different things
and it
it's kind of tricky sometimes to say
precisely what we're mapping things onto
so
you know with with things like that i
think the correspondence theory
breaks down a good bit you know
i mean another problem too is it's not
like we ever really encounter
facts that are
not clothed in some sort of
interpretation
or connection with other things
um i mean there are some things that we
can talk about like that you know
the bare taste of the tea that i'm
drinking right now
but anything that really matters is
going to be
involving some some interpretation
you know and so the correspondence
theory of truth acts almost as if we
have this
unmediated access to to reality
it makes me i mean so good as makes me
think a little bit of
our investigation into the quantum realm
and or even just you know not even that
you can go down to electrons and we have
probability clouds of where these things
reside but not
a you can't say like for there there is
an electron here
you can say like there's a uh a a 93
probability that electron was in within
this
volume around the nucleus of an atom
um yeah yeah and that might be off but
like you know once once we get to
certain areas we just don't have the
ability
and we might never have ability because
the uh you know the world of
kind of newtonian physics that we tend
to live in
uh yeah yeah on the macro world yeah
breaks down when we're getting into this
really small
that's a good point yeah i hadn't
thought about that um
i i think there's i mean there's other
issues as well that will come up but
let's jump to the course to the
coherence theory of of truth
this is often you know like
counter-posed so you don't want to have
a correspondence theory you have a
coherence theory and the coherence
theory says no one single proposition is
true
in and of itself it's when you put them
together and it could be propositions it
could be thoughts it could be whatever
you're using to model these things
it's when you put them together in a
system
in which they at a very basic level
don't contradict each other
but you know ideally there's more than
that they
they're relevant to each other they
cohere with each other they complement
each other right
and it's when you put all these things
together that you get
truth and the truth is in the coherence
of these different you know bits of
meaning with each other
and and i think that there is something
to this i mean
think about how we use language or think
about
the discipline of mathematics you know
coherence does work for for those sorts
of things and a lot of what we
take for granted you know our picture of
the world
isn't really a correspondence of what's
in our head to the world it's
it's much more like you know do our
thoughts actually map
on to each other is our little map
inside our head coherence
you know so that's that's important and
i know some thinkers take this very far
like
um hegel for example will say things
like you know the truth is
in the whole or their totality um
which means that most of us are out of
touch with truth most of the time
unfortunately or the truth that we have
is just like a little t truth not not a
capital t truth like good old hegel has
and i don't think we have to go that far
with it in order to get
get something out of this but then we
have to ask ourselves well how do we
figure out if things are true or false
well we take
all these ideas or propositions or
whatever you want to call them
and we bring in some new thing and we
say well does this actually
fit these or or not and if it doesn't
fit them
then we say oh it's false you know um
well
either it's false or we need to change
something else
if you've got something that is too
smacking the face
as true yeah yeah then then something
else has to
budge right in this model of reality
ideally i mean
there are people who can put up with an
awful lot of contradictory ideas
bouncing around in their head aren't
there you know i mean the cognitive
dissonance is supposed to be like this
painful uncomfortable sensation
some people like seem to thrive on it
so i don't know um and i know you wanted
to talk about
um one one of the big problems with this
is right that we have
um just because a you can
have a wholly consistent and coherent
world and philosophy um this does not
automatically mean it's true and so for
example you can
you can make a sci-fi novel on
as uh and everything in there is is
totally
internally consistent and everything is
good in that regard
but you know it is a thing of pure
fantasy
um and so you you have to have if you're
going to have something that is
trying to bring you back to truth within
the world that we live in and the people
that we live with
um there has to be at least some
grounding
here and there um to reality i'm kind of
thinking of like a hot air balloon
as this idea of this coherence theory
and if it's
totally unmoored and it gets flown and
it goes
wishing through the sky and then i i
to even take that to an extent you know
take
certain um political philosophies that
lead to
atrocities and and killings of like
millions of people
and they you know if you look at most of
them they have a very coherent world
view
and everything that they they choose to
do
is for some value that they consider to
be good
but this um vast majority of other
people
do not hold to this and so if if there
has to be
one truth then one of these things has
to give
and and how are you going to arbitrate
between
these different world views yeah and i
suppose if you say
well you know let him fight it out and
you know the most true one will
live or you know replace the other
you've left the coherence theory of
truth behind you've got now got a
different kind of theory of truth might
makes right
yeah basically or um
i mean that can fit in to some degree
with the
notion of truth as socially constructed
where power struggles are part of it
you know the the things that we consider
to be true
are in some respect they're true it
relativizes things true
things are true within a particular
society or culture
that in which that truth is constructed
and that construction often does involve
some
you know power differentials or
exploitation or violence or something
along those lines
i mean to be fair there are a lot of
truths that actually are socially
constructed i mean
you know the stuff that we do in
economics basically
i mean to say that something is a social
construction a lot of people hear that
they're like oh man it means it's
totally fake and
you know we could change it overnight
like when people talk about race being a
social construction
race here in america is a socially
constructed idea
there is no such thing as white or black
or hispanic or asian
in terms of like absolute you know
genetic truths or anything like like
that um
you know we we can isolate different
people coming from different places
that's what like 23andme does
but there it's not like those
definitions that we use
um the ones that we use in the u.s
census and the ones that have like
historical weight to them
it's like well you know you've got this
gene group from this person
group over here in this part of europe
and
this thing from you know iran and this
thing from over here and
most of us actually when we take these
tests turn out to be quite a mix and a
mess
yeah that's kind of why i like the the
different
i guess term of the on intersubjective
reality
yeah instead of the social construction
because
it it kind of comes down to this idea
that we have objective realities this is
a glass
on yeah uh subjective realities like um
i think the water tastes pretty good and
and interest-objective realities like
money and corporations or race in this
regard but they
um all these things because we
socially agree that they are something
they can move um and
uh change uh and affect us all
the same way that uh objective reality
does
and so yeah and they do so historically
through complex dynamics you know
i mean think about our our own city of
milwaukee right it's considered one of
the most segregated large cities in the
united states
and it's not like you know at one point
in time people are like
hey everybody uh get in your own group
and go over there you know
instead it was all these complex
processes that did have to do with
people labeled as this race this race
this race and then legal ramifications
and then
you know where the schools went and
where the where the work went and how
transportation worked and where you
could buy a house
exactly yeah yeah i mean those things
are
are realities um but they relied upon
things that were in fact
whether we call it socially constructed
or inter-subjective
um they weren't based in like the order
and nature of things
you know i mean it's interesting because
one of the things the stoics
actually use as an example of an
indifferent
the color of somebody's skin black or
white
they use that as a classic example back
in the ancient time
we should uh i mean we're not going to
get to everything i think let's talk a
little bit about about pragmatism
um do you think it's really pragmatic to
talk about that in such a short amount
of time
it could be practical okay
you know we're not going to go deep into
it but
um there is this notion that um
was well you know was brought about by
these american thinkers like
charles sanders purse and william james
but who by the way had a beef with each
other over the name pragmatism
uh john dewey is another good example
richard rorty
is a more contemporary example and the
idea is that
truth it's similar to the coherence
theory but also it brings some things of
the correspondence theory truth is
what works for us what
satisfies certain needs or desires
meets human interests ties in with what
james calls our
volitional or passional nature and when
people hear that they often get a little
nervous they're like
so anything can be true so long as you
like it
and that's not what the pragmatists are
saying because that's not really
practical i mean people get themselves
in all sorts of trouble doing things
like that
you know doing get rich quick schemes
they're more saying
listen you can use the the coherence and
the correspondence theory of truth
um but you do have to recognize that
there's a lot of things that
are true or are false on the basis
of whether they actually do work or not
so if i if i have a proposition like
so and so would be a good um
significant other for me you know
somebody i could i could be involved
with
if you don't actually operate according
to something and maybe go on a date with
somebody and
put those beliefs into action you're
never going to find out
and and what counts as good for me
i'm willing to bet is a bit different
than what counts as good for you
in that respect we we probably don't
have exactly the same criteria and we
have to kind of figure this stuff out
along the way and so sometimes we have
to say
did it work didn't it work you know um
and so i think that's that's part of it
i think we have to realize we do so i'll
leave you the words
of arthur schopenhauer all truth passes
through three stages
versus ridicule second it is violently
opposed
and third is accepted as being
self-evident
[Music]
[Music]
you